and irony we've been waiting for another  breakup song from Taylor Swift and her  bestie Gigi Hadid confirmed to ET ahead  of her show at New York Fashion Week new  music is on the way  what does it mean to you that Taylor's  come out to support you tonight  she's obviously such a great friend and  you know she is starting to go back to  work into the studio again and really  made time to be here for me so I'm on  Friday t-swift made her first public  appearance since her split from Tom  Hiddleston to support Gigi's new fashion  collection with Tommy Hilfiger how  excited are you to present this  collection to your girls squad it's your  family it's your boyfriend how are you  feeling about that  I'm really really excited  funny enough  that's t-swift lip-synching to the song  she co-wrote with her ex Calvin Harris  Taylor Odin the caption quote so proud  of you Gigi that show was insane  Congrats to G Tommy and all the girls  who just owned that runway